es ist das ende einer langen reise
konnte holtorf nach seiner letzten
etappe am brandenburger tor in berlin
mit seinen geländewagen den er otto
nennt hat er 890.000 kilometer
zurückgelegt so viel wie 22 mal um den
äquator stolz am ende der tour aber auch
etwas melancholie nach 26 jahren
mittlerweile ist der 77 jährige in
seinen heimatort das bayerische
gollenshausen zurückgekehrt hier
arbeitet er die reise auf von seiner
tour hat er eine karte anfertigen lassen
mit einem auto ist niemandem zuvor so
eine reise gelungen ein eintrag ins
guinness buch der rekorde ist in
vorbereitung
wenn ich mir diese karte heute angucken
kann ich mir nicht vorstellen dass ich
an all diesen vielen dessen gewesen bin
dass insbesondere der otto an all diesen
firmen setzen gewesen ist die ich auf
der gabel los geht es 1988 mit dem
geländewagen auto fährt heute auf kreuz
und quer durch afrika seinen job als
geschäftsführer einer fluggesellschaft
hat er gekündigt seine inzwischen
verstorbene frau christine ist mit an
bord
ihre abenteuerliche tour finanzieren sie
mit ersparnissen zwei jahre wollen sie
unterwegs sein
doch als die vorbei sind fahren sie
einfach weiter auf dem containerschiff
reisen sie mit otto nach südamerika von
dort aus geht es in die usa
und dann weiter in den norden bis an den
polarkreis
sie reisen nach australien und
durchqueren danach dem gesamten
asiatischen kontinent bis hinauf in den
himalaya
zivilisation war es am schönsten
das bedeutet die wüste nicht nur die
sahara die berühmte sahara auf die name
büste oder taklamakan in china also die
wüste wo wir alleine waren ihnen gelingt
sogar die einreise in abgeriegelte
länder wie myanmar und nordkorea als
erste westliche ausländer sind sie dort
mit dem eigenen fahrzeug unterwegs
alles geht glatt bis auf einen schweren
unfall ereignet sich auf madagaskar vor
der küste afrikas gemacht aber hat auch
die geländewagen otto wird auf der tour
zu ihrem rollenden zu hause fast jede
nacht schlafen die holdorfs in dem
fahrzeug ein kanister dient als
improvisierte dusche und auch eine
mobile küche richten sie sich ein
otto war für uns sicherlich ein stück
heimat otto hat uns sicherheit gegeben
in geborgenheit das ist sicherlich der
richtige ausdruck
wir haben uns in dem motto wohlgefühl
autos künftiges zuhause ist das mercedes
benz museum in stuttgart
der weitgereiste geländewagen wird teil
der automobilausstellung für
unterhaltung auf heißt es jetzt
endgültig abschied nehmen
erinnerungen an die reise gibt es zum
glück genug etwa die vielen
zeitungsartikel aus aller welt
die deutsche zeitschrift stern hat die
tour in einem umfangreichen online
projekt aufgearbeitet viele bilder
zeigen konnte holte auf mit seiner frau
christine 20 jahre waren sie gemeinsam
unterwegs 2010 verstarb sie nach langer
krankheit
nach ihrem tod bin ich wieder
aufgebrochen
auch um das doch sehr sehr belastende
erlebnis ein wenig vergessen zu können
und habe dann in den nächsten vier
jahren lässt sich bis heute als das noch
gemacht was fehlte doch jetzt hat erst
einmal genug vom reisen nach der vielen
zeit hinterm steuer genießt er die
beschaulichkeit am heimischen chiemsee
ein buch über die reise ist in planung
doch allzu eilig hat konnte heute auf
ist nicht nach 26 jahren ist günter
holdorf angekommen
nicht nur an seinem heimatort sondern
irgendwie auch bei sich selbst